we've got a voicemail number that number  is two one nine to david p here is the  rare positive voicemail this one from a  liberal gun owner take a listen David my  name is Greg Walker I'm a 55 year old  liberal veteran gun owner gotta tell you  I listened to your broadcast I like it a  lot keep up the good work hold their  feet to the fire mmm don't be  intimidated right well listen if the  veteran liberal gun owners are with me  then we are going to continue we have a  great bonus show planned for you today  you can get instant access by going to  david pakman.com slash membership and of  course if normal membership rates are a  bit high you can use the coupon code i  voted 17 to get a sizable discount